wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
mir ist vollkommen egal womit sie sich
in ihrer freizeit beschäftigen aber die
nachbarn haben sich beschwert hat sich
beschwert
etwa herr merz vorüber denn na ja es war
den ganzen tag über sehr laut und da war
ein großes gedränge vor der eingangstür
ein großes gedränge ich gebe doch nur
wieder von mir berichtet wurde
ja natürlich sie hätten nicht einfach
vorher anrufen können wofür gibt es
heutzutage handys wir haben den
hauseingang extra freigelassen und zudem
hohe zeit mal ist wieder abgebaut
ich habe nichts falsch gemacht ich meine
worüber reden wir hier eigentlich haben
sie nichts besseres zu tun
wir engagieren uns für flüchtlinge und
sie interessiert nur der lärm überlassen
sie das doch besser den politikern
ich finde dass politiker viel zu wenig
tun
also müssen wir es eben selbst mehr
engagieren
warum engagieren sie sich nicht direkt
in der politik vielleicht mache ich das
ja sogar
[Musik]